my name is steph faso from al jazeera  english  bombing children's hospitals maternity  wards residential areas they seem to be  part of the strategy to force you to  surrender this is clearly not working  but it must have an enormous impact on  you mentally regarding the children and  the beautiful mothers and what happened  to them how can any normal person react  to this well it's simply an act of  terrorism another one unfortunately this  is like a tragic tv series about acts of  terrorism  when this has happened elsewhere in  europe like when there's been an attack  on a metro station everyone was shocked  today we're all apparently used to it i  don't want to be used to it  heavily guarded the president has just  left this room but these kinds of  appearances are very important not only  for the ukrainian army for the civil  defense but also for a lot of civilians  who are staying behind here in kiev and  in the rest of the country to fight this  war  you